some of the techniques that we're
talking about tonight are still used in
highly modern manufacture I mean jet
planes still have forged elements and
mostly now and in some of the high-tech
industries we use forging and we even
use it in the clock project the 10,000
year clock you can see these stainless
ring forgings these are basically when
you want to get if you were gonna try
and make a certain a large circular
thing out of stainless steel now making
it all a disk cutting it out of plate
would cost way too much money so you
actually get these ring forgings made
you machine those and then you so you
get this what's called near-net objects
made and so we did that for some of the
largest bearings that are in the clock
these a whole series of 30-inch bearings
that were that we built for the clock
and so it's a it's both an ancient
process and it's an extremely modern
process at the same time and I think the
other thing that's important to
understand about about forging is its
it's very different than most of the
modern processes that we now have it
used to be for the last kind of hundred
years we've really been using reductive
processes which means you have a milling
machine moving through steel or metal
that's removing from a large block and
so you're doing reductive processes and
now everyone's very excited about
additive processes where we're adding
layers of plastic or even metal now to
create things with 3d printers and and
that's that's what that is but what
we're talking about tonight is really
what's called effectively a plastic
process where we start with a lump of a
thing and you don't really get to change
its mass fundamentally you just get to
move its mass around and so you actually
have to your brain has to think in a
very different way to create things with
forgings than it does for some of these
other processes and it's you know I
think many of you have heard the old
adage you know how did you know
Michelangelo how did you carve that you
know the Pieta out of stone he's like
well I I started with the stone and I
removed everything that wasn't the Pieta
right and so that's that's one way of
thinking about how to
create objects but this way is is I
started with this mass of stone and I
pushed it or clay in a way it's more
like clay I formed it into that object
but I never got to change its mass
fundamentally
[Music]